Justin Bieber Selena Gomez ariana grande
and Taylor Swift are some of the biggest
celebrities in the world they all come
with huge fan bases of incredibly
talented people who can easily transform
their looks into practically anything or
anyone including anime characters wait
until you see what Miley Cyrus looks
like as an anime if you're a fan of any
of these celebrities give this video a
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to our Channel today we're discussing 10
celebs reimagined as anime characters
Justin Bieber if you think Justin Bieber
is cute wait until you see Justin
reimagined as an anime character the
Canadian pop sensation first started
getting some attention with his YouTube
where he managed to impress practically
everyone with his extraordinary singing
talent in 2009 he released his first
debut album and you could say that the
rest is history
Justin Bieber has one of the largest fan
bases out of any pop star so no wonder
someone took the time to draw him as an
anime character see we told you he looks
cute this beautiful illustration belongs
to a deviantART user white fuzzy hero
the anime version of Justin has big
brown eyes and a hoodie over his head
his hair from his teenage years was
perfect for an anime character judging
by the look of this youngster this anime
justin is from his 2009 era when every
one of us was singing his pop hit baby
in 2010 his music video for baby became
one of the most watched videos on
YouTube since then many artists
including psy Taylor Swift and himself
managed to set a new record for most
views on a music video we still hold a
special place in our hearts for Justin
especially when he looks like an anime
character one direction but if you don't
like Justin Bieber you probably like One
Direction just a little bit more
although the group has permanently split
up in 2016 many still can't get over the
boys who have charmed our hearts and had
us singing to tune such as what makes
you beautiful and perfect the five boys
Niall Liam Harry Zayn and
we all have unique looks and
personalities so why don't we have a
look at what they look like as anime
characters this illustration belongs to
deviantART user 1 Direction fan John can
you tell which member is which we
believes Ain is on the far left next is
Louie
then Niall Harry and Liam at the end the
artist did a fantastic job highlighting
individual features of the boys such as
their eye color but he also added a tiny
detail that many one Directioners want
to see come true in real life can you
tell what it is he shopped Harry with
one of the other members of the band did
you know that the boys first appeared on
x-factor and even though they didn't win
the competition they became the most
famous X Factor contestants ever even
though One Direction isn't together
anymore the band is still one of the
most successful boy bands in history and
even though it might never be possible
to see them all together ever again
each of the boys is now hugely
successful on their own Selena Gomez
some celebrities really can pull off an
anime character like no other and Selena
Gomez is one of those people her facial
features already make her look like she
belongs in the Disney World but this
artist decide to take her to the world
of anime instead and honestly Selena is
a perfect fit for an anime character
this anime version of Selena belongs to
a tumblr user called flawless Bieber the
artists nickname fits her because we
think this design is flawless just look
at how gorgeous selena looks as an anime
character
what kind of anime do you think she
would belong in we bet that she'd still
be a pop princess even as an anime in
fact her anime look doesn't look that
much different from her real-life
version and her big gorgeous eyes stand
out even more here's another fun fact
about Selena Gomez do you remember this
water park girl from Spy Kids 3d you
might not believe it but that right
there is Selena Gomez at the age of 11
isn't she the cutest and she looks even
cuter as an anime character Taylor Swift
and we can't talk about Selena Gomez
without mentioning her BFF Taylor Swift
the queen of shake it off and blank
space Taylor has been on the music scene
since the age of 14 and she's known as
the artist who successfully switched
genres from country to pop and managed
to reach an even bigger fan base her
fans are called the Swifty's and they're
a tight-knit community that is lucky to
get Christmas gifts from Taylor Swift
self a very talented Taylor Swift fan
nicknamed Turkey Wang reimagined Taylor
Swift as a shibi character she B is one
of the three basic Japanese styles and
it means a small and short person
although Taylor Swift is anything but
short she still looks exceptionally cute
as a she B character what do you think
this version of Taylor sports a slightly
longer blonde hair big eyes dark clothes
and of course her guitar
she looks like she's ready to rock the
house we wonder if her voice as a she B
character would still be the same or
would she have a pitch adjusted to her
cute sighs did you know Taylor Swift is
5 foot 10
she towers over many celebrities which
is why seeing her as a she B character
is slightly unexpected Nicki Minaj
speaking of Taylor Swift remember the
short 2015 feud she had with Nicki Minaj
after she misread her tweet and thought
it was about her of course she then
quickly apologized because you don't
want to mess with the one and only
self-proclaimed human Barbie Nicki Minaj
already is an interesting person so
reimagining her as an anime would only
highlight her personality and amazing
looks
this illustration belongs to a deviant
art user cam batch flop and it sends
Nicki right into the world of anime the
anime Nicki Minaj is sporting a
schoolgirl outfit long dark hair lots of
bling and a fierce personality did you
know that Nicki Minaj wanted to be an
actress in high school perhaps this is
why she was so convincing as her
alter-ego Roman who made an appearance
on quite a few of her songs from her
album pink Friday we'd love to see her
Roman character reimagined as an anime
but perhaps it's eccentric personality
would best work with something like
manga art which anime show do you think
Nicki Minaj would best fit in we see her
in Sailor Moon although the show would
then become just a bit more fierce and
sassy kylie jenner another celebrity
whose features could translate into an
anime character is kylie jenner
whether you hate her or love her you
can't deny that kylie jenner is gorgeous
with her long dark hair big brown eyes
and beautiful lips she fits the
description of an anime character this
version of kylie jenner is made by a
deviantART user nicknamed al is 7 and we
love it if that's even possible Kylie's
hair looks even more gorgeous when
illustrated as an anime she could
probably
Nicki Minaj in the celebrity version of
Sailor Moon and we think the next
celebrity on our list would be a perfect
fit to complete this gorgeous trio but
for now let's discuss Kylie Jenner did
you know she was on the same cheer squad
as her sister Kendall in high school
she's one of our favorite Kardashians
and she admitted to Kim and Kourtney
that she feels she was never supposed to
be famous in the first place the
Instagram selfie queen is without a
doubt fabulous but there's no such thing
as perfect Kylie has a huge scar on her
thigh that she got playing hide and seek
with one of her sisters when she was
little nevertheless she's gorgeous and
would make an ideal anime character
Melanie Martinez here's the last but not
least member of what we think would be
an ideal Sailor Moon trio imagine nicki
minaj kylie jenner and melanie martinez
going on adventures and fighting crime
using their superpowers Melanie Martinez
is a singer who makes alternative music
but she's also known for her outstanding
performance of Britney Spears toxic on
NBC's The Voice she has quite an
interesting look that would be perfect
for an anime character and a deviantART
user called so Cola made it all possible
check out Melanie as an anime we love
her half white half black colored hair
and the added purple eyes that worked
even better than Melanie's dark brown
eyes she even has freckles and a cute
bow on the top of her head did you know
that Melanie Martinez is one of the most
successful pop acts that initially
emerged on NBC's The Voice her style
remained the same to this day
and Melanie admitted she doesn't own a
single pair of jeans but that's okay
because jeans aren't exactly the first
choice of clothing with anime characters
she'd fit right in the anime world come
on someone needs to make the anime trio
with Nicki Minaj Kylie Jenner and
Melanie Martinez happen Katy Perry there
are only a few people that can beat
Melanie Martinez as alternative looks
and Katy Perry is one of those people
the famous pop star is known for her
sometimes quite extreme fashion that
never fails to make the news and there's
just something about her features that
makes us think she'd be a perfect anime
character the deviantART user Zim and
shuffle fan made it all possible and
turned Katy into a super cute anime
character the original image looks like
this and we can safely say that this
Katy Perry fan really did it justice
from flowers in her hair
her to heart detail on her belt this
artist really didn't miss anything when
making this anime character Katy Perry
had a lot of hair colors over the years
ranging from red purple green all the
way to blue she says her favorite style
was her green hair and we have to agree
although many try not a lot of
celebrities can pull off Katy Perry's
unique fashion style that would work
perfectly with the anime world did you
know that her real name is Katherine
Elizabeth Hudson and that she had a cat
called kitty purry her cat even won an
award for best celebrity feline what's
your favorite Katy Perry fashion era
ours was her awesome blue hair and candy
dress Miley Cyrus if there's a celebrity
who is the best at showing their unique
personality it's Miley the famous singer
had us dancing to songs like party in
the USA and we can't stop Miley Cyrus
sure has changed her style since you've
seen her on Hannah Montana and went from
a small-town girl from Tennessee to one
of the most controversial pop sensations
in the music industry tumblr user
flawless Bieber recreated Miley as an
anime and we loved it
this illustration is definitely from her
controversial we can stop era when Miley
was sporting a short blonde haircut and
a full white outfit she looks a little
bit shy but we all know that the real
Miley Cyrus is anything but a person who
holds herself back and it's why we love
her Miley has also sported an anime like
look during her hosting of the 2015 MTV
Movie Awards like this pink haired pink
outfit style which anime do you think
she'd fit in we bet they could have
easily turned Hannah Montana into a
successful anime show speaking of Miley
Cyrus did you know that her real name is
destiny hope Cyrus the name Miley
actually came from her childhood
nickname ariana grande and last but not
least it's the queen of modern pop music
ariana grande Grande's climbed to fame
began as an actress on the 2010 show
victorious this is when she gained a
very impressionable fan base and quickly
climbed the music charts she's often
compared with Mariah Carey and Whitney
Houston because of her outstanding
singing voice but it's also her unique
look that wins over people's hearts she
has big eyes long hair and she's shorter
than some of her younger fans her looks
would work perfectly as an animator
vector and these illustrations really
did her anime version justice we are
totally in love with both of these
illustrations one showcase is the fun
side of Ariana with her cat ears and the
other is much more powerful the new
Ariana Grande era also features
ridiculously cute cat ears or the black
bunny mask have you ever wondered why
Ariana chose the black bunny mask as her
theme for the dangerous woman album she
hasn't addressed this herself the many
fans speculate it's a new form of a
superhero especially since the pop star
herself talks about female empowerment
and taking a stance for what you believe
although Ariana hasn't been on the music
scene for that long she's certainly one
of the biggest pop sensations at the
decade what's your favorite ariana
grande song let us know in the comments
do you have a favorite celebrity you'd
like to see reimagined as an anime
character let us know and don't forget
to give this video a thumbs up for more
videos like this one check out ten kids
cartoon characters reimagined as adults
see you in the next video